an extended family of 10 some of them
small children all killed say their
relatives in an american airstrike
as a us drone destroyed a vehicle that
americans say have been carrying suicide
bombers a tragedy that darkens and
complicates the withdrawal from
afghanistan even further significant
secondary explosions from the targeted
vehicle indicated the presence of a
substantial amount of explosive
material
we are aware of reports of civilian
casualties and we take these reports
very seriously and we are continuing to
assess the situation
the last hours of america's pull-out
remain at grave risk from further
attacks this was the launch vehicle for
another attempt at hitting u.s forces at
kabul airport
[Applause]
rockets unleashed from an improvised
launch system some missing their target
others destroyed by anti-missile fire
as the last flights leave kabul a
diplomatic scramble is underway to
contain the fallout of the taliban
takeover
urgent meetings between allies and
british ministers insisting they're
doing what they can
ensuring that the taliban uh stick to
their commitments in terms of
maintaining the international security
sorry internal security within
afghanistan
is important and of course we will have
to keep a very very close eye on what
happens in afghanistan to make sure it
doesn't descend back into a haven for
terrorism
exactly how that's avoided isn't clear
intelligence veterans say there's no
option but to find some way of working
with the taliban it's a challenge as
much for the taliban as it is for the
west uh and that so that is where the
shared interest is if they want to
remain in office they want to remain in
power they want to remain they want to
be an effective government they've got a
very strong interest in finding some
help and if we fail what's at stake our
own security but also i mean a key
country you know in a
in a part of the world where instability
will no will spread the taliban has a
little experience of governing risking a
slide into further anarchy outside banks
ordinary afghans were already queuing to
get their money out
food charity handouts are being mobbed
by hungry crowds they need money they
need the reserves to be unfrozen they
need development assistance they need
humanitarian assistance
if they're going to
prevent afghanistan from sinking into
even greater poverty and chaos a day
after the last of our troops returned
home finding a way of working with the
enemy they fought for two decades is
already a priority
dominic waghorn sky news